Searchlight Pictures presents The Roses, only in theaters August 29th. From the director of Meet the Parents and the writer of Poor Things, comes The Roses, starring Academy Award winner Olivia Coleman, Academy Award nominee, Benedict Cumberbatch, Andy Samburg, Kate McKinnon, and Allison Janney. A hilarious new comedy filled with drama, excitement, and a little bit of hatred, proving that marriage isn't always a bed of roses. See The Roses Only in Theater's August 29th. Get tickets now.
I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hello. Hi.
Welcome back to Office Lady. 86.0. Angela, are you ready for some jump scares? Maybe some airy music and a really scary villain. Why would I be ready for any of that? I don't know, but you better get ready because today we're breaking down the webisode, the third floor, which is all about Ryan making a horror movie. Well, Jenna, I know you're very excited for today's episode. You love a good horror movie. Love. I hate them. Mm-hmm. But I want to tell you, I'm just thankful that there are no zombies in this one because I really hate zombies. I love zombies. Give me all the zombies. I mean, Ryan tried to have zombies. We'll get to it. Yeah, I know. I got excited. This is one thing you and I do have in common, though. What do we have in
common? Well, I don't know if we should talk about it, but we both had a really strong reaction to the season of The Last of Us. You know, Josh had me watch it. He wanted me to watch it. I know. How did Josh get you to even start watching this? You watched the whole thing. first season. Yes. And then you got hooked. I was very excited because this is our first zombie crossover moment. Yeah, I mean, I love Pedro. Pedro Pascal. Well, we all love Pedro Pascal, which is why this season was so very upsetting to us because we didn't play the video game, everybody. Jen and I didn't know. We didn't know what was going to happen. And after it happened, I was so upset. Spoiler, if you, okay, if you don't know the video game and if you haven't,
watched this show yet. Just like... Fast forward, maybe. Fast forward, because I actually need to talk about this. And I know we're a little late to talking about it, because everyone expressed this same outrage about two months ago. But truly, if you haven't played the video game and you haven't seen season two, just fast forward about 50 seconds from now. Yes. Guys, Pedro Pascal's character has the most gruesome death in episode two, in episode two. I kept waiting. I was like, Wait, what? Shirley, oh, here she comes. She's going to come rescue him.
No, no, no. And here's the thing. I'm not watching it anymore. I can't watch it anymore. He was my guy. You broke my heart. Why would I keep going out with a guy who broke my heart like that? Like, the show is a man who I was in love with, and he fucking trampled on my heart.
I can't go back to him. I can't go back to him. It was too much for me. And I sent a text to our group thread where I was like, what is? And I googled. I was like, what am I? You're three like angry messages, like angry long messages about what the hell just happened here. Yeah, we both were pretty bummed about that. Josh is still watching. So he has continued without me. I was like, I can't. I was like, babe, here's the thing. You can't ask me. As someone who hates zombies, I hate zombies. Yep. You can't ask me to watch a zombie show with the one thing that kept me watching it is gone. Yes. That was the only reason I was there.
Okay, it wasn't the only reason I was there, but I am so distraught that I have not been able to keep watching it. I think I might. I think I will get over this hurt. But listen to me, everybody, we all know. I was trying to explain it to Lee because Lee doesn't watch it with me. He's like, I don't get, like, just this one person died. I'm like, babe, babe, it's Pedro Pascal, okay?
He is like, I tried to come up with, like, an analogy. I was like, he is, remember what Meg Ryan was to like an 80s romantic comedy movie? Just like an utter delight from the moment she's on screen until the end. Yeah. Like, just makes you happy watching her. That is the feeling I get when I watch Pedro Pascal in anything. Just a delight. I'm happier now. You know what it is for me? I'm invested. Whatever he's in, I'm so invested. I still really,
really need you to see his Ark in Game of Thrones. I really need you to get to Dorn. I am so sorry. I saw a red carpet interview with him where someone said, will you ever have such a brutal death as you had in Game of Thrones that will upset fans? And he said, yes, I think there will be because he knew what was going to happen in The Last of Us. I still need you to see him in Game of Thrones. Sam. Yeah, I need you to watch that episode at least. I don't want to just tune in to see him die. You need to see the minute he comes on screen, his presence, it's so different from the other characters you've seen him play. I need you to see him.
My introduction to him was in Game of Thrones. Okay, my introduction to him was in Narcos. Oh, he's great in Narcos. Okay, I will watch Game of Thrones for Pedro Pascal, like done. I will do it. What season is he? Like, how far in? I mean, could she just pick up with that season, Sam?
She doesn't have to like watch all the way too when they have the Dorn brothers, sisters on. So he first appears in season four, episode one. Oh, my God. Cassie. You guys. I say, just go there. Don't. I got pretty far in the Game of Thrones when I committed to watching it.
Like, I'm pretty sure. I've told you, like, when is that red lady on that extra island? Yeah. Isn't that, like, in season three or something? No, no, you're not talking about the red wedding. You're talking about the red lady who had sex with the black smoke. Oh, okay. Yeah, her.
Yeah. I don't know what season that is, but that was around where it lost me. I would pick up. I would start season three. I would watch season three and then treat yourself with a first episode of season four at the end. Have you seen the Red Wedding episode? I don't know what happens in a Red Wedding. Oh, you would know.
Never mind. Never mind. That's a great episode. Okay. Okay. Well, we might have to make a list for her. Well, you know what? We should probably take a break because when we come back, we are going to break down the third floor.
And Jenna, as our resident horror movie expert, you're going to give us your assessment of Ryan's attempt at this genre. I will. I will. I tried to give it my best critique. Okay. But that's not all everybody. I gave Angela an assignment that I'm so excited about. I asked her to watch the first 24 minutes and 30 seconds of John Carpenter's The Thing. Yeah. Because that is about the same amount of time that I watched the first John Wick movie on my first viewing. I have completed it, everyone. But Angela said she would watch that same length of any horror movie I chose. And I did. And I have no idea. what her reaction is. Don't tell me yet, but I cannot wait to hear your thoughts. And Angela, I want you to know that I tried really hard to pick a movie that was not just a horror movie, but also a classically great film. I didn't just try to give you some slasher scary thing. That's true. And I appreciate that. I truly knew nothing about this movie before I watched it. I did not Google it. I did not look it up. I really watched it not knowing anything. So it was just my honest reaction as I started watching it, and I will share that with you. All right. Well, we'll take a break and be right back.
This is an ad by BetterHelp. You know, it feels like nowadays there's advice for just about everything. It's like, do you write in your journal, do you do, I don't know, cleanses or the cold plunge or, you know, what helps you get through the day? What helps you get through stressful moments? Mm-hmm. For me, it's talking it out. Mm-hmm. Well, there can be a lot of information overload about mental health and wellness, and it can be a struggle to know what's true and what actions to take these days.
So you might think about using a trusted resource and talking to live therapists through better help. It has an app store rating of 4.9 out of 5 based on over 1.7 million client reviews. As the largest online therapy provider in the world, BetterHelp can provide access to mental health professionals with a diverse variety of expertise. Talk it out with BetterHelp. Our listeners get 10% off their first month at BetterHelp.com slash office ladies. That's BetterHelp, H-E-L-P.com slash office ladies. All right, we are back, and this webisode series has some really fun bonus content. on Peacock.
Like, there is this cool black and white film flipbook of behind the scenes of this shoot. It was really fun to watch. And you know what? There's also some interviews with the cast. I thought we should kick this off with what Mindy and BJ had to say about this Webisode series. The episodes are following the tradition of the characters wanting to put on a show. Ryan is directing a horror film that he thinks will be sort of.
the paranormal activity set in an office picked up by the documentary crew and by the main characters in the office like the little things that fall through the cracks i think that's the best thing to show in webisodes so i really liked when the group did a subtle sexuality that girl band that kelly and aaron did and i really like this horror film that they're all working on it's funny like the side projects that just get completely ignored by everyone in the office and somehow for the web episodes we capture them i like that i'll do too so it's really fun that they get to explore what Ryan's passions or hobbies are. And I guess he's a big horror film fan. Well, I think it's more that he's a filmmaking fan. And this, to me, kind of goes with
his character trait of how he got into photography for a while. I feel like the horror movie part is just his way into being a, like, film director. Oh, yes, and entertainment. Well, there's more cast interviews. We'll sprinkle those in as we go. Well, here are a few stats about this webisode. It was released on October 28th, 2010. This was during season seven of the office. We aired the episode costume contest the same day as this webisode. It was kind of our nod to Halloween. This webisode was also nominated for a Webby Award. So episode one is titled Kelly and Aaron Move On. This whole series of webisodes were written by Kelly Hannan, Jonathan Hughes, and Mary Wall, and they were directed by Mindy Kaling.
Here is your summary. Kelly and Aaron are going to pivot away from subtle sexuality. They're not going to make music anymore. Their new creative outlet is going to be acting in Ryan's horror film. Yeah. As a series starts, we are at front reception. Kelly and Aaron are listening to the tail end of their song. I'm just the girl next door.
Aaron thinks it's their best one yet. But they are disappointed by how many views the video is getting. It's not getting very many. Two. Two. That's it. That's it. Dare I say it's the two of them watching it. Kelly declares that music and dance are dead.
That's it. That must be the reason. Yes, that's why. Erin does add it's also the economy. Oh, okay. So there are multiple reasons. They say maybe it's time to move on. But don't worry, they're not giving up on fame.
They're just giving up on music. So we cut to a little sitting area outside the break room. Kelly and Aaron are now with Kevin. They are sitting on the floor. They're having a floor chat. Yes, like a little brainstorming session. I've never seen this staging before. I found it super creative and interesting and fun. Fun. Yeah, I loved it. It kind of reminded me a little bit about when there was that group in the little supply closet having a meeting like Kelly and Toby. Yes, that was added back to the super fan episode. of what was that hot girl? Yes. Yeah.
Yeah. It was a really, really creative way to shoot this. Kelly has like a little pad of paper, I guess for her brainstorming session. I need you to hear how Kelly kicks things off. Okay. I want to express myself, but I have nothing to say in no medium with which to do it. That's it. She has something she wants to say. She doesn't know what it is.
She has no way to do it. Go. Go, give it to me. Kevin, you're up. Well, Kevin explains that there's more than one way to express yourself, and he reveals that he writes poetry. What? All along, Kevin is a poet? He reads one of his haikus. Here's what it is. Beauty approaches. I am brought under its spell. I long to be with. That's it. Because he ran out of syllables. We'll never know. Ryan is in the adjacent room, and he is yelling at someone over the phone. He's very upset. Yes. He's talking about, like, ancient zombies, traipsing through Scranton out for blood.
Ryan is on the phone with someone trying to get them to participate. Mm-hmm. It sounds like he needs... Would you say? Yes. It sounds like he needs a lot of background actors to play zombies. Yes. And we find out that he is called the Evergreen Old Folks Home. Yes. I need to play this talking head where Ryan describes the film he's trying to make, but more than anything, I need you to hear when it cuts back to his side of the phone call with the
manager of the retirement home, because what he says just cracked me up. Picture this. Fifty ancient zombies traipsing through the pothole-ridden streets of Scranton, out for blood. Sounds scary, right? too bad you'll never see it because the idiot manager at the evergreen old folks home thinks it sounds exploitative so that's where we're at right now okay your level of hysteria makes me think maybe you're not in charge is there a supervisor I hope that's what your level of hysteria makes me believe you're not in charge look what I wrote my favorite line in this episode is when Ryan says okay your level of
hysteria makes me think you're not in charge I literally want to, like, put that on a post-it note for the next time I might need it when I'm trying to talk to somebody who is not helping me on a customer service call. You know what it made me. Some version of that. Like, your level of helpfulness is making me think you're not in charge. It actually made me think of Cassie because how you guys call Cassie, you and your partner call about your cable. I thought the same thing. I thought the same thing. I was like, Cassie needs to say, okay, your level of hysteria makes me think you're not in charge.
I'll try it in the next six months when we have to make that call. So Ryan explains his situation to Kelly, like what's going on, and Kelly volunteers to be in the movie. Yeah. Ryan is going to reject this idea. But then Kelly's like, look, I scream all the time. I'm really good at screaming. I can scream for free. And he's like, okay, fine, fine. Yeah, he says, if the director of paranormal activity can make it work. So can he. Yeah. I'll have you know I've not ever seen paranormal activity. Well, shocker, neither have I. Sam? The first one is very, very good. Yes. You guys have seen it? Yes, the rest of the six or seven you can skip. Six or seven. I'm not kidding, but the first one is really good. I can't watch, I have some limits. Oh, I didn't know this. Yeah, I was going to explain this a little later when I was sort of talking about my passion for horrible.
movies, but I don't love supernatural horror or haunted house stories. And paranormal activity is kind of both. Is it because you could believe it? I don't want to feel creeped out in my own home. Like, I already have a problem sleeping if I hear any creaks or noises. So I don't need, like, extra food for that. That's so interesting because that's the only type of horror movie I like to watch. Really? Yeah, I only like ghost stories. I don't like someone trying to kill and stab me. See, I can't fight back against a ghost. So, like, I don't know how to win that scenario. Oh. Yeah, I think it's because I don't believe in it. So it's... Yeah, I mean, we've talked about how I have the lady in my closet and all that stuff.
Listen. So I just don't need to imagine her getting angry at me or anything. Yeah. I mean, I am like, I am not messing with the spirit world. You know what I'm saying? That's how I feel. Like, I am not messing with it. I think I've shared this with you guys that I was going to audition for a role in the movie The Conjuring. And they sent me the script. And this is when we were on the office. And I ultimately had a conflict. But they sent me the script. And I was like, oh, I'll read it. And I was reading it in my trailer on the set of the office, like on my break. And I was so terrified. It scared the crows. It scared the crows. Rapola, just reading it. Wow. Scared the crap out of me. I wonder if being in the movie would have been some sort of like therapy for that, though, because you would see how fake it was. No, no, no, but it's based on a true story. Oh, yeah, that's right. That one is. It's based on a true story. And I did see that movie and it's really good. Yeah. Okay. Anyway, okay, so you do have limits to this genre. I'm glad to know that.
I do. Because I don't want to watch anything where some ghost is coming for me ever, ever. Well, I did not pick that for you. I know. Well, this episode of the web series ends with Kelly and Aaron. They're so excited that they're going to be in this movie, you know, that they're back. And they start singing this little song, and it goes like this. We found our outlet. We found our outlet.
No more singing and dancing for us. We found our outlet. We found an outlet. We found an outlet. Go to two minutes and 34 seconds because Kate Flannery is just being Kate. She's not Meredith at all in this moment. Look at her. She's just Kate. She's just eating chips. Yeah. Kind of bobbing her head to their song. Yeah. All right. Next up, episode two titled Lights Camera Action. It opens with Angela making a copy on the copy machine when Aaron
wielding a butcher knife jumps out and scares her. Angela is very upset, but Ryan is thrilled. He is thrilled. He says, Aaron, you were amazing. And then he turns to Angela so earnestly and goes, You are so good. And Angela's like, I am just scared. And Angela comes to find out that the knife that Aaron is wielding at her is not even a fake knife. They were too expensive, Ryan says. We have plenty of real knives. They probably should have got a faky knife that looked more like a real knife because that knife is so clearly fake. I thought it looked like a faking knife, too. That's so funny. Well, you know, when we rehearsed the scene, they said, okay, Angela, they didn't know what I screamed like. You know, they were like, you're going to get a jump scare. Just scream like you're terrified. And Brian, as Kevin is standing kind of close to me, and I screamed like I screamed.
And Brian looked at me like, what the hell? It kind of made him jump. Now, here's my question. We have discussed that when you jump scare Angela Kinsey, she might kick or punch you. Yes. Because you really do not like it. My first instinct is to hit. Yes. So how was this for you shooting this? I feel like this is your tickling scene. Remember how I really hate being tickled, but I had to let Roy tickle Pam and Pam had to like it? It went against all my instincts. This was okay for me because Angela is angry. Okay. She's furious. She kind of slams the papers down on the copier. And so that was, I could play that. You could use it. I could. I was furious that they were jump scaring me.
Okay. Well, in this moment, we also finally get to see Aaron's costume. Right? And Mindy and Ellie share in these behind-the-scenes interviews about it. I am the monster. I'm a combination of Jeffrey Dahmer on, let's see, this side and Lizzie Borden on this side. She looks hideous. When I first saw her, like they would bring her in, like, Laverne brought her in, costumes, right? And we're like, what do you think? And I was, like, recoiled because it was so good. It was like so gruesome and terrible. Oh, I have no doubt that hair, makeup, and costumes had so much fun with this. Oh, yeah. I do love that Mindy said she looked hideous. I reached out to Ellie about this. I sent her a screen grab of her in this costume. And I said, Ellie, please tell me anything that you
remember about the hair and makeup process for this look. And I sent her a picture of herself as this character. And she wrote, and then she said, oh my goodness, this webisode, I loved it. That was absolutely the longest I was in hair and makeup at the office. Wow. It was two to three hours. Wow. Yeah. She said, and get this, I still have the poster. She said, but I don't know where to display it. Oh, they made a poster? They made a poster of her looking like that. Okay, that's pretty cool. I know.
But I also get why maybe she isn't hanging it in the hallway. She should just hang it up as a Halloween decoration every year. Oh, that's a great idea. Yeah. Okay, well, Jenna, as our resident horror movie expert, what did you think of Ellie's costume as this monster character? I thought it was fantastic. I thought they did a great job with it. It was very, very creative.
But the costuming I really want to talk about is Ryan as the horror movie director. Oh, I had a whole thing that says right here, we have got to break down Ryan's outfit. Yeah, I would describe it as full douchebag. That's great. And in my limited time in the sort of horror movie circles through my fandom and getting to meet the horror movie director. They really do dress like that. Do they really? I mean, he's got on the Elvis sunglasses from like the Vegas years.
He's got on a zip-up hoodie. And like a beanie. Yes, but his zip-up hoodie isn't just a normal zip-up hoodie. It looks like the x-ray of someone's chest. I mean, listen. The rib cage. Maybe they don't dress like this anymore. But like back in the day, it was a really weird way of dressing.
and it made me laugh out loud when I saw him. I was like, I have literally met that guy. I think I actually know who they are satirizing with that outfit. Like, I think I know. I won't say. Oh, come on. But I think I know who it is. And it made me laugh out loud.
You have to tell me later. Yes. I love the guy. But yes, there's like a whole like presentational outfit. Oh my gosh. I have no idea who this is. Yeah. Well, now Gabe is talking to Ryan, and he's explaining to Ryan, look, you can't scare people in the office.
Yeah, Ryan's like, I'm sorry. I don't remember seeing anything in the handbook about not being able to shoot horror films in the office. And Gabe is like, well, it does say you cannot bring weapons to work. Right then, Aaron appears with an axe, and Kelly yells for Gabe to run. Gabe is completely panicked. He's in a corner. He's like, there's nowhere. Run, where?
There's nowhere to run. And then Ryan's like, got it, got the shot. Yes. Turns out Kevin was filming from over at Kelly's desk. Then Gabe is now angry at them. And he says, quote, it is petrifying and frankly unprofessional, this behavior. To which Ryan replies, it's unprofessional for you. But for me, making films is my profession.
Oh, Ryan. Oh, Ryan, Ryan, Ryan. Gabe threatens to. stop all production. And Ryan pivots quickly in the moment. And he's like, wait, your voice just then. It sounded so commanding. Yeah.
And he asked him if he will be the voiceover talent for the movie, the narrator. Gabe is instantly flattered and agrees to do it. I want everyone to go to one minute, 36 seconds. Why? Everyone is breaking. They are. But DJ. What?
Ellie is breaking, but she kind of just makes it part of her character. Mindy is trying really hard not to break. Brian is breaking so badly that he ducks behind BJ. He turns his body and tilts his head down. What are they laughing at? And then when it cuts back to Zach Woods, he looks like he's trying not to laugh. So I don't know what happened in that moment.
I have a feeling, Zach Woods improvised a few moments here. I bet he did. I mean, if I had to think about it, I feel like maybe he started doing some sort of like voiceover bit thing. Or when he says my voice is so nasal, it sounds like dot, dot, dot, I bet he gave them a bunch of different versions of what his nasally voice sounds like. You're probably right. But they are all losing it.
That's very funny. Well, Ryan realizes that he's going to be the first filmmaker to wear all four hats. Wow. Writer, director, actor, and producer. Wow. Gabe mentions that Clint Eastwood has already done that multiple times. But then Ryan says, but does he play his own? score. And he has a saxophone that he starts playing. Where has the saxophone been this whole
scene? It's just like ready to go? I guess so. And who knew that Ryan plays the saxophone? Who knew? This is the big reveal at the end of the episode. Kevin's a poet. Ryan plays the saxophone. We're learning so much. So much. Up next is episode three. It's titled The Final Product. And before we get into this breakdown, I have to share this little nugget from the behind the scenes interview. It's Zach Woods talking about trick-or-treating as a kid when he was growing up. It's hilarious. When I was a kid, I was really into Halloween. I got my friends together and we choreographed a full dance to the Bee Gees.
You know, the staying alive? I would lip-sync. We would bring a boom box and go from door to door, and then we would press play. And I would lip-sync staying alive. And they would do this whole choreograph dance behind me. I remember going to one man's door and doing this whole choreograph dance and day he was like, do you want candy? I can't wait all night. He got real irate and I remember immediately being like, oh, this was a terrible idea. I want to see footage of that. I need to see
Zach Woods as a kid hitting a doorbell saying trick or treat and then singing the beechees. Like, I need that in my life. I feel like we need to remind him of this story that he told because if you've done that, that's ingrained in you. Oh, yeah. I feel. feel like he could, he could, like, bust that out any time. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. All right. Well, listen, episode three, the final product is exactly as advertised. It is the movie. Mm-hmm. There is this sort of opening title credit, and it's got a warning. It says, quote, the following preview has been approved by the Motion Picture Association of Evil and is suitable for sadistic audiences only. Watch at your own risk.
Yes, we open on a voiceover, and it's Gabe. And he is narrating that she thought it was just another typical day at work. And who he's talking about is Kelly, who is conducting an interview with Meredith, who is playing, what would you say, like a fortune teller type of woman? She's got a shawl over her head, kind of wrapped around her neck. She's got a patch over one eye. She wants to buy some paper, but she has no money. And when Kelly won't sell her paper, Meredith puts a curse on her. Yeah.
She summons serial killers from the past to unite and haunt the third floor for all eternity. And Kelly's like, whatever, this is the second floor. So I'm all good. I'm not on the third floor. Yeah, it's fine. She doesn't care that she has caused a. curse for everyone on the third floor. You got it wrong, lady. Yeah. Now we see Kevin, and he's in his mall cop outfit. Remember his Halloween mall cop? Oh, yes. Yes. He's got a toupee, a mustache. He's like the
security guard character. Yes. And it's dark. He's using his flashlight. He's in the hallway, kind of out by the elevator bay and Vance Refrigeration. And he sees Aaron wielding the axe from earlier. Yes. It's actually a cool shot. You sort of then see. a shadow of him and you see a shadow of an axe hacking at the shadow of him and like blood splurting everywhere. It cuts to Creed. He has a talking head. You guys, he's a member of the press. He has a hat and he has a little sign that says press. He is. And I need you to hear this talking head because he's going to tell you what's happened and it's great. I've never seen anything like it. Has the right arm of Lizzie Borden, the left arm of Jeffrey.
Domer, the heart of Jack the Ripper, and the legs of all the serial killers who ever got away. So there you have it. That's our monster. I also love the callback to saxophone playing. Oh, I didn't even, I just heard that in that clip. This is right. He is playing the score. You're right. So during this creed talking head, as he's describing the monster, we see Aaron as. the monster in B-roll, she's got an axe in her Lizzie Borden hand, she has a fork in her Jeffrey Dahmer hand, and then you see her sort of like wobbly legs getting ready to run. Erin now goes after Angela, then Gabe.
Yep. Kelly asks the janitor, who's being played by Ryan, why are these crimes happening on the second floor? Remember? Because it's the third floor that's curse. Well, he tells her, they added a basement during. renovations. So this is the third floor. Kelly's like, Kelly begs the old woman to reverse the curse. But it's too late. The murdering corpse of
Aaron appears at Kelly's cubicle and then sort of like low speed chases her through the office as Kelly begs for her life. She tries to throw a candy dish. That does make Aaron trip for a minute. This is true. She does trip. But she bouncing. bounces back up. And when Kelly opens the elevator door, she's like hitting the button, hitting the button. Yep. And it opens and there is Erin. Inside the elevator. She's transported. Yeah. And she kills Kelly. The title card flashes on the screen. The third floor. Coming to theaters, TBD. TBD. And there you have it. There you have it. How fun to shoot this. It was really fun. I love doing my scene. And I know, Ellie, had a blast as well. These episodes were always so much fun. Yeah. Because you got to just do so many
wacky things. But lady, let's go to break because when we come back, Jenna, will you give us your overall assessment of Ryan's movie? I will. And Angela, you will share with us about watching the first 24 minutes and 30 seconds of John Carpenter's The Thing. I will. Get to Toronto's main venues like Budweiser Stage and the new Roger Stadium with Go Transit. Thanks to Go Transit's special online e-ticket fairs, a $10 one-day weekend pass offers unlimited travel on any weekend day or holiday anywhere along the Go Network. And the weekday group passes offer the same weekday travel flexibility across the network, starting at $30 for two people and up to $60 for a group of five. Buy your online go pass ahead of the show at go-transit.com slash tickets. We are back.
All right, Jenna. Let us know how does Ryan's movie fare on your horror movie scale. Okay. I wanted to do a good job with my critique. Okay. So according to the Internet AI, there are certain elements that all good horror movies have. Oh. And I agreed.
Oh. So a great horror movie is a blend of atmosphere. I would add that a good horror movie also has a few jump scares and a great villain. Whatever that villain might be, maybe it's a ghost, maybe it's an actual monster, maybe it's your own dark thoughts. Okay. Okay. I think Ryan's film has it all. Wow.
Yeah. Are you surprised? I thought it was great. I thought it was a really good. about if I am a local filmmaker and I'm making a movie in my office with my friends, I thought it was excellent. Wow. I thought it had a great plot. The plot was very clear. I thought it had good suspense. I thought there was great atmosphere with Kevin as a security guard, kind of wandering dark in the hallway. Like, I thought it was a great use of the space. Like, again, if I'm imagining
that Ryan is a real person and Dunder Mifflin is a real place. I thought he used the space creatively. I thought it was shot well. I mean, probably because Matt Sone was shooting it, but it's shot very well. But I would argue that there is one thing that it is missing. What? I think a good horror movie has creative kills. Oh. And in this one, we kind of get the same kill over and over. It's just sort of the same bloody handprint going down a wall. Well, that might have been all of the special effects they could afford. And also, because the people they were killing, they weren't part of the movie. So they couldn't really, all they were getting was just like someone screaming and then a
bloody handprint down the wall. Sure, sure. Like Angela Martin is not going to participate. She's like done. Exactly. Right. But honestly, I felt like it was really pretty good for a homemade horror film. A plus for homemade horror film.
I thought it was great. Well, well done, Kelly Hannon, Jonathan Hughes, and Mary Wall. Great writing. And great directing Mindy. Yes. So, lady, two thumbs up then? I would give it two thumbs up. I would.
But, you know, that is for the circumstances that this film is made. I did think maybe I could give a list of my favorite horror films that are like a real big thumbs up for me. Okay. Just because, you know, I do love them. I'm very curious. Okay. Well, I already mentioned that there are certain subgenres of horror that are not my thing. Like, I am not a fan of the supernatural horror or The Haunted House.
We talked about that. But I also do not love torture horror. Oh, no, no. I don't want to see any of that. Those are movies like Saw or Hostel. No, thank you. Those are torture horror. No, no.
And I've seen them. I saw the first Saw. I saw the first Hostel. They were too much for me. I also don't usually go for Monster Horror, which, Which is what the third floor is. But isn't that also the assignment you gave me? No.
That is not necessarily monster horror. I think maybe it is, but I'll get to that. True, just like solid monster horror would be like Texas Chainsaw Massacre, Halloween, Friday the 13th, where there's like a masked killer on the loose. Okay. Like a type of just monster after you. Okay. However, I love zombies.
love, I think that's a kind of monster, but for whatever reason, that one makes the list for me. I also mostly love, my favorite, my favorite is psychological horror and paranoia horror. And I think that is what the thing is. The thing definitely has monstery elements, but it's mostly paranoia horror, and that is my favorite genre. So do you like the movie What Lies Beneath? because I think that's, like, very scary. Do I know that movie?
What Lies Beneath? Michelle Pfeiffer. Yeah. Yeah, it's great. It's really good. Okay, well, I will watch it immediately. Crap out of me. Okay.
I watched it years ago not really realizing that it was a scary movie, and it's terrifying. I cannot wait. Do you agree? Yeah, it stands up. Oh, I can't wait. Okay. This is so exciting. I didn't think I would be giving you a suggestion.
What a gift. Okay, you'll have to let me know. But, like, paranoia horror would be like invasion of the body snatchers. Ooh, ugh. I love the Donald Sutherland invasion of the body snatchers. No, thank you. I love Stapford wives. Oh, I haven't seen that.
So here is my list of 10 favorite horror movies for all y'all out there who might want to partake. But before I give this list, full disclosure, I have not seen the Babadook or Midsummer. I don't know what that means. Have you seen the Babadook? I have. I think you would like Babadook. I don't think you would like Midsummer. Babadook is great.
Highly recommend. I need to watch it. Yes. Yeah, especially based on your parameters of what you like in horror movies. I think you'll like it a lot. Okay. But it has a kid in it. And another thing that sometimes scares me is when a child's trying to kill their parents.
Well, you'll see. Okay. Here we go, Angela. Don't watch this movie, but it is by Peter Jackson, who is, you know, Lord of the Rings. I know. He made a horror film. One of his first films is a comedy. horror film called Dead Alive.
It is... Is it zombies? Kind of. It's people get infected. It is the goryest... No, thank you. Movie I've ever seen until this year's movie
with Demi Moore. The substance. The substance. Yeah, no, I didn't see that. When I saw the substance, I was like, there we go. You've taken the crown from dead alive. Something I thought could never happen.
Okay, number two on my list is Final Destination 2. That's the one with the truck. That's the one with the truck, Sam. The first one is the plane. The second one is the truck. I have seen none of them. Don't drive on a highway again
after you've seen Final Destination 2. Number three, I put this on here. I saw it a long time ago, and it was a favorite of mine for a long time, but I haven't been able to get myself to rewatch it, which is Cabin Fever by Eli Roth. Cabin Fever is good. It's great. It's great.
Okay, number four, the dissent. Oh, thumbs up from Cassie. Cassie's out of her chair standing up. Yes. Angela, it's all women. It's all women, spalunkers. They go in a cave. Yeah, no, thank you.
I don't want to be trapped underground with anyone. It is an amazing horror movie, and it has this underlining theme of, like, dealing with grief. One of the women has had something happened in her life, and they go spulunking to kind of, like, help her through this difficult time in her life. and there is stuff in the cave. Yeah, well, yeah. It's very orc-like, lady. No, thank you. Imagine orcs in a cave.
No, thank you. Okay, number five is It Follows. I don't like anything called It. Oh, you would like It Follows. I think you would like It Follows. I don't think so. It Follows also has a great theme about women and what would you say? The perils of misogyny.
Original sin, I guess. Yeah. It's great. Number six is David Cronidberg's The Fly. I have seen the fly. Similar to the thing, I think. Yeah. I saw that like in college and like I look at flies differently now. How can you not? How can you not? It changes you forever. It does.
Okay. Number seven, George Romero's Dawn of the Dead. The original Dawn of the Dead. Not the Brad Pitt one. Brad Pitt isn't in any of the Dawn of the Dead. No, he's in a zombie movie. Thank you. thank you. Yes. The remake of Dawn of the Dead is also very good. Yeah, it's all zombies. I'm not doing it. Number eight is a nightmare on Elm Street part three. This is my exception to not loving monster horror. I actually love Freddie Krueger because there is a paranoia element with not being able to sleep and people not believing you that someone's attacking you in your dreams. In high school, all of my friends got together and they made me watch Nightmare on Elm Street. I hated it. I hated it. I
hated it. Well, number three is the one where she actually gets put like in an insane asylum and then like they're drugging her to go to sleep. And so she like gets super stuck in her dreams and Freddie Krueger. It's so good. Number nine, another paranoia horror, the faculty by Robert Rodriguez. That's, um, what's his name? He's having a resurgence right now. Josh Hartnett. Yes, that's right. Sure is. He's so good. Elijah Wood's in that too. Mm-hmm. I think so. Angela, how would you be with like a comedic like Sean of the Dead? I watch Sean of the Dead. Okay.
Yeah. And that? It was okay. I didn't like the zombie part. Okay. Fair enough. All right. And then finally on my list, and I'm saying it 10th, but it might be my number one is John Carpenter's the thing.
So, Angela, I am turning it over to you. I cannot wait to hear your assessment. And you saw, I just want you to realize, of the 10 movies that I just listed, I really, I really picked the one that I thought you would actually like. Well, I really appreciate that. I really do, because all of those that you listed prior sounded horrible, and I'm thankful I want you to know that those were the other choices. Yeah.
Well, you know what? In rewatching the third floor and all of these behind the scenes interviews, I did discover that I'm not the only the office cast member that doesn't like horror movies. Okay. Here's what Mindy and BJ had to say about the genre. I actually feel very uncomfortable in horror movies. I'm not a horror fan. I'm not a horror guy.
I can't even say the word horror. It sounds like something else when horror. So I have good company, but I did watch the thing. And lady, I videoed myself so I could see and play back my honest. reactions to watching it. You videoed yourself? I videoed myself watching it. I watched it during the day in the afternoon because I didn't want to get scared. And I have all these videos of me watching it. Oh my gosh. And reacting in real time. And here are some of my very first reactions. I am quoting myself. I transcribed the video. Okay. Because to play it would be 24 minutes. And I thought I can't play 24
minutes of me reacting. Okay. So I will share with you my first reactions to this movie. Okay. All right. I cannot wait to hear these. Sam, Cassie, Jenna. And the thing is, I have the whole video, so I can't share part of it in stories, maybe. Here it is. First of all, I should tell you that this movie has a very slow build. Mm-hmm. And I was so invested that I ended up watching the whole movie. Oh my God, my ears. Oh, my God! Oh, God. My ears of my ears.
Okay, that was such a great reaction, Jenna. Oh, my God. You watched the whole thing? I watched the whole thing. What? You watched it all? But it is, like, I had you cut off at, like, the most cliffhangery spot. You did.
But with enough time to reveal the first, like, monstery gross thing. Okay. So here were my. first reaction. I was just going to ask you, because you did text me and you said I might need to watch a little further. And I was just wondering if you got to the dogs. That's all. I was like, I wonder if I can't believe she didn't turn it off after the dogs. Okay. Okay. Like I said, I started to just record myself watching it for the first time. And I ultimately just hit stop because I didn't even want the distraction of myself watching yourself. Yeah. And my periphery.
I just was so invested in the movie. I just wanted to be an audience member. It's a good plot. It's a really good plot. It's a simple plot. Here are my first reactions. And now I am quoting myself, creepy music. Just film titles and creepy music.
Yeah. Still film titles and creepy music. It goes in a while. Oh, it's a starry night. Something's flying in the sky. Oh, it's a spaceship. It's like burning through the atmosphere. Now it says, the thing.
And there's like lightning. The screen now says Antarctica, 1982. It looks really cold. So cold. So cold. There's a helicopter. They're getting lower. There's a guy like leaning out of it with binocular things.
Oh, there's a dog. I think it's a husky. It might be a wolf. I can't tell. It's running like crazy. Running, running, running. The dog just looked right at the helicopter. And now it's running.
Oh, no. They're going to shoot it? Why? I am so mad. at this helicopter right now. Run, dog! Jenna? I'm going to be so mad if they kill this dog. Oh, wait, there's a sign. United States National Science Institute Station 4. Oh, there's a lot of dudes. There's a ping pong table. They're making whiskey. Oh, they're drinking whiskey. Oh, it's Kurt Russell. He's playing chess like on an old-timey computer. Wait a second. This computer has a
really sexy voice. She's like, my move to Rook 3. Kurt is very scruffy. I like it. Oh, he lost. And he's so mad. He's like pouring whiskey into the computer. He fried it. Hey, there's a guy on roller skates. There's a guy on roller skates. And then I just really freak out because I'm like, now the helicopter's circling back. Now they're firing at the dog. What is wrong? Then he gets out of the helicopter. And then he like throws a grenade. But by accident, I think he throws it backwards and he burns up his own helicopter. blows up his friend and his whole helicopter. Yeah. What was the first time you yelled out loud at the screen? Oh. When they were shooting at the dog?
Yes. I have it. I have it on video. Oh, there's a dog. There's a husky. He's running, running, running. He's looking at the helicopter. And now he's running away from the helicopter.
And the helicopter's like coming in. Anyway, it's running. Oh, no, they're going to shoot it? Why? You can't shoot the dog? Anyway, okay, so what we learn is this helicopter, they're speaking Norwegian. Yep. And they, like, are trying to shoot the dog.
Right. One of the American guys shoots the Norwegian guy because he's shooting at the dog, but he ends up shooting one of their dudes in the leg. Yeah, I mean, all the Americans know, these American scientists in Antarctica, all they know is that a helicopter is landed. It is blown up. Someone has left the helicopter and is shooting. at them. And so they kill the guy, and then the lone survivor is this dog that they then adopt. That they bring into their science station in Antarctica. But this one guy is a doctor, and he's like, hey, I want to know, like, where they, what's going on with them? Maybe they've gone
stir crazy. Like, let's go see. There's a storm coming. That's never a good thing. And then the guy, Kurt Russell, plays Mack. He wears like a... By the way, you're welcome. I, only gave you the Pedro Pascal of his time. Oh, he's... Mr. Kurt Russell. He's scruffy and super hot. And his voice is amazing. He's Mac.
He's Mac with his sideways cowboy hat. He drinks so much whiskey. Everybody drinks. Everyone's drinking. They're drinking constantly. I don't understand how they ever get any work done at this facility. Okay. Whatever they're supposed to be doing there.
Mac and this doctor, they go to the Norwegian station, right? Yeah, to see, like, what happened. It has been blown to bits. It's charred. It's frozen. Yep. And they find this, like, grossest looking thing. Thing. It's so gross.
It looks like it has two heads and multiple appendages. And the doctor's like, we're taking it back with us. I'm like, what? That was the second time I yelled, Sam. But hold on. It's not going to matter if they brought that thing back. Because the dog is there. The dog is already there.
You don't know that. You don't know that. that. So right now, I'm thinking, you're idiots. Why would you take this weird thing back? And then immediately they get it back and they start an autopsy on it. It's so disgusting. That's where I stopped it for you. I thought maybe that's all Angela can stand. No, I was in. I was in because I'm like, this thing on this autopsy table is going to kill them all. But what I didn't know is the dog I had been rooting for all along. Yep. Had been mutated by the thing.
Yep. And it splits in half in a dog kennel and all these like things come flying out of it. And it like, it gets all the other dogs. Yeah. And part of it you see wiggles out. Yep. And I'm like, oh, that's going to. This is a perfect description of the movie The Thing.
This is perfect. And then immediately I'm like, they're all dead. We know this now. They're all going to die. Listen, we don't have to describe the whole movie to you, but it is so good. It's very good. And it goes on and on. And there is such paranoia because they don't know who's infected and who's not.
It's very hard to tell who's infected. Also, they're not great at communicating with one another. And they separate. I'm always like, why, when they're like, you two go there. I'm like, they're dead. Here's the other thing about this movie that is so amazing. It's from so long ago. There is no CGI crepull.
in this movie. It's not computer-generated. It is all practical effects. I have to give a shout out to the special effects guy. It's Rob Botton, and he was only 22 years old when he did the effects for this movie. He also did the effects for Total Recall. You know that scene in Total Recall where the lady's face splits open? Oh, yeah. That's him. But the practical effects in this are nuts. How about the scene where I'm sure you didn't see it coming? I don't know how you made it through it when they go to do the like the kjunk of the CPR
on the guy who like has the heart attack and they do the kajunk yeah and then you know what happens his whole he explodes his whole chest opens up and like a giant mouth
like eats off the hands of the person who was doing the kajunk yes yeah yeah no spoiler it was listen it doesn't matter that I've told you it's still gonna fucking kick your ass when you see it. Listen, that was disgusting, but honestly, the part when the dog exploded and then all the
little things came out of them was worse for me. Once I had seen that, I could handle whatever else that thing had coming for everyone. Yeah. The way it does absorb other people is so disgusting. And the one guy on roller skates keeps like finding people's clothes ripped. And he's like, hey, you guys, do a better job cleaning up. I'm like, they're dead. They are dead. And what I also really liked about this movie was just how much time and patience the director had. He was so patient. He didn't rush any moment. And I really liked that. And then I thought the ending was just so good. So good. It does not wrap up with a bow.
And I really liked it. I really liked it. I'm so glad, lady. It's a great person. performances. It's great writing. It also has a little bit of like that survivalist aspect to it. I'm always interested in things that are set in wilderness or like the cold, you know. I love that it's just this, the isolation of these people, you know. Oh, yeah, winter has just set in. So they're, they're just screwed. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, one of the comments I didn't share was the very first time I saw the giant ice cube. Oh, yeah. I was like, giant ice cube probably holds some kind of Frankenstein thing. Not good. Yeah. But yeah, great movie. Great movie. I liked it. Thank you for suggesting it and not making me watch those other ones that would have been too much for me.
Well, I just have to say, lady, now that we know that I have watched Lord of the Rings and I've seen the orcs. Yes. I'm not sure there was much more about this movie that was more gory or terrifying than like an orc being born in Lord of the Rings. Oh, no, it's disgusting. The way they kind of plop down in that gelatinous, like, giant mud hole. No, it's so gross. What is it about horror movies you don't like? Because it can't be the violence and the gore.
Because you watch very violent stuff all the time. Narcos, Game of Thrones, Lord of the Rings. Like, what is it that you don't like? I don't like, like, like, suspense. Ah, I don't like... The stress of suspense. I don't like waiting for the jump scare. Just get to it. Okay. So like, and that makes sense to me because a lot of the violence in Game of Thrones, it's like revenge or war or something, battle. You can do battle. Yeah, when I see a battle scene, I'm like, okay, they're here to fight. Right. It's going to go down. Right. But if I'm just walking
into my kitchen late at night, pour myself a glass of milk, sure. I open the fridge and then I open the fridge and And then I shut it. And there's a guy there. I don't like it. I get it. And I know it's coming. I know it's coming. Also, one of the things, like right at the beginning of this movie, there's this for no reason an establishing shot of a big tank of gasoline. I'm like, oh, they're going to need that. Like, now I'm waiting. I'm waiting. What do they need the gasoline for? Yeah. Yeah. All right. Well, my heart is so happy. Thank you for the gift of watching this movie and for liking it. I did not know if you. I mean, I just didn't expect you to like it, but I'm so glad you did. It's really well done. It's really well done. There you go, you guys. Look at that. Jenna, we're just like, in our friendship, we're just encouraging each other to grow and experience new things. This is a really exciting year. We're in our 50s. And look at us. We're doing this. This should prove to anyone. It's never too late to experience something new.
all right well thank you everyone for joining us today i love this webisode and i love today's episode yeah and thank you to ellie kimper for always answering my crazy text messages and we hope you guys have a great week we'll see you next time thank you for listening to office ladies office ladies is a presentation of odyssey and is produced by jennifer and angela kenzie Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbico. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz.
Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.